in indonesia's sikka regency yet another
young life has been lost to covet 19.
funeral workers have come to take this
coffin to the cemetery
inside is the body of a two-month-old
baby
her name was maria
she died in hospital almost three hours
from her family's home
now her parents have returned to their
village
we came back here from the hospital
because our child is dead
all they have are their memories of
maria they don't even have a photo of
their daughter
i stay at home and rest because i'm
always thinking about my daughter who
died
as indonesia's culvert crisis continues
even the youngest have not been spared
and in many parts of the country
children may also be suffering from a
second disease or medical condition
which heightens the risk
stunting or malnutrition will have an
impact on a child's immune system so if
they get infected it's likely to hit
them harder
a slow vaccination drive outside major
cities is also putting young people in
danger as many children contract the
virus from family members
people said children not affected and
children couldn't die
but right now we have a lot of children
die
as the delta variant continues to spread
across indonesia more children are
falling ill each day
every week hundreds of indonesian
children die from covert 19. most are
under the age of five and as the death
toll increases so too does demand for
small child-sized coffins built for the
country's young victims of the pandemic
jubeira still cannot believe her
granddaughter shalovah is gone she was
just four years old
she was kind and cute everyone liked her
i'm sad she left me behind i still want
to take care of her but god decided
otherwise
shalovah never got the chance to ride
her new bike hers like thousands around
the country was a childhood cut short by
the pandemic
jessica washington al jazeera tangarang